welcome back to CBS Mornings in our
series we call protecting the planet
we've got some good news this morning in
the fight to save threatened bee
populations did you know the bee
population is being threatened yep the
U.S government recently approved the
world's first vaccine for honeybees we
rely on those insects to pollinate the
crops that provide much of our food
supply as senior National and
environmental correspondent Ben Tracy
shows us scientists hope that this
breakthrough could be key to saving a
crucial species
in California's Central Valley massive
Orchards of almond trees are blooming
and buzzing with activity I can hear
them buzzing around us yeah they're busy
at work Brian ashhurst runs the ash
Hurst Bee Company he's a fourth
generation beekeeper how many bees do
you keep we run about 27 000 colonies
his bees are part of one of the largest
pollination events on the planet
California produces more than 80 percent
of the world's almonds and each Blossom
is pollinated by a bee oh see that's a
nice looking frame and Ash Hertz bees
are very busy we do broccoli we do
avocados we do watermelons we do onion
seeds we do carrot seed that's a lot
yeah there's quite a bit that goes goes
on bees pollinate one third of the food
grown in the United States essential to
producing an estimated 15 billion
dollars worth of crops annually but bee
colonies are collapsing due to disease
parasites pesticides and even climate
change fueled droughts which dry up the
water and flowers they need to survive
they're just decimated sometimes 50
percent I've heard guys losing 70
percent so we're constantly trying to
figure out how can we reduce these
losses Jurg Meyer is a professor of
Zoological medicine at the University of
Georgia and we can informally also call
you a beekeeper oh absolutely I'm a
certified beekeeper yeah open it up
carefully hello bees he somehow
convinced me to take a look at his
teaching hives you're not noticing that
a lot of them attack you right so
they're really good well maybe in five
minutes that might change
he constantly inspects these to make
sure there are no signs of diseases like
the dreaded American foul brood doesn't
sound good no what exactly is this so
it's a it's a bacterial disease and what
happens after a few days it's so bad
that those little developing bees The
Brood dies and they die and it smells
really foul so you have foul brood foul
smelling brood it's so bad the
government requires infected hives in
all beekeeping equipment to be burned
and buried there is no cure for the
disease and until now no vaccine to
prevent it so we literally had to start
from scratch Annette kleiser is CEO of
dalon animal health which partnered with
the University of Georgia to develop the
world's first honeybee vaccine how
challenging was it to figure out a
vaccine for a bee well we were the first
ones to do this there was no handbook it
was very challenging because unlike
humans and animals insects don't create
antibodies so scientists have long
thought vaccines simply won't work but
in the lab they discovered bees have a
primitive immune system and exposing a
queen bee to some of the Dead bacteria
through her food created immunity in the
hive I mean it's like magic you
vaccinate the queen and she passes it on
onto the millions of offspring that make
the colony
so far they have not seen any side
effects or impacts on food products such
as honey the hoop is this breakthrough
will pave the way for other vaccines to
control all sorts of harmful viruses and
pests that's good Brian ashhurst says it
won't solve all of the problems killing
bees but he's optimistic are you willing
to give this vaccine to your bees yeah
I'm willing to try it out I think
because we're all looking for answers
for things we're willing to try things
out because the one thing we do know is
that without bees these fields would be
a lot less fertile for CBS mornings I'm
Ben Tracy in California's Central Valley
oh I'm rooting for the bees if not for
honey I wouldn't be able to get my kids
to eat the like brown healthy cereal we
put in the bowl every morning and then
slather with a whole bunch of honey this
is the coolest story I was going to say
but I love the behind the scenes look of
what they're doing yeah 100 and just the
Notions human Ingenuity and Science and
you figure out a way to you know
vaccinate an entire Bee population that
is so cool yeah really cool Ben thank
you